hey everybody and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be showing
you how to customize the autofill
effects in your safari web browser so
i'm just go ahead and open safari right
here and the easiest way to do this is
to go to edit and preferences
and this is the preferences uh window of
course that comes up now what we're
going to think is security
oh not security sorry
um autofill there's an autofill button
in the um the preferences
preferences window and first of all you
can say using info my for my address
book card i can autofill tons of stuff
i'm going to exit here so you don't
actually see it but yeah you can use
info from your address book built into
windows vista
to use autofill
second is usernames and passwords so if
you have any
websites with usernames and passwords
obviously
it will remember them you can obviously
remove all remove one or two from the
auto automatically remembering list and
also it doesn't have pictures in here so
i guess i can show you but yeah it
doesn't have passwords so it it actually
does remember the password so whenever i
actually go to
maybe facebook.com to login it'll have
exactly all the things that i need
filled in even if it doesn't log in
automatically and last is other forms so
maybe i have uh maybe i'm logged into a
forum website i can actually go look up
and find that forum website
and um
that the password username and password
will automatically be filled in so i'm
going to show you guys a few examples
i'm going to go to
geeks
geeksdotpro.com a pretty sweet website i
advise you guys to go check it out if
you haven't already and when it's done
loading right before it's downloading it
won't actually be there but when it's
done loading it'll actually show you
guys my email and my password and i just
hit login i don't actually have to type
this all in now of course the
fingerprint logo will show up saying oh
you could have swiped your fingerprint
to log in because i have a fingerprint
reader but yeah that's not the point so
what else can i show you i can show you
um
google.com i think i'm already signed in
but basically all right mistyped
but yeah it'll it'll say yeah i'm not
signed in yet so i hit the sign in
button
and
safari will as the page is loading say
hey look there's the email and password
key we should definitely check that out
they check it out and they say well we
already have this in autofill so all you
have to do is hit sign in and you're
signed right in
so that is the easiest way to manage
your autofill in safari internet browser
hope you found this tutorial helpful and
thanks for watching subscribe peace